along with europeans this morning we've
also had the gdp we've also had gdp
figures out not 0.3 contraction in april
not quite what people were necessarily
expecting rin
yeah we're still seeing a weak economic
outlook at the moment and
we do think the economy as a whole will
grow this year uh so we'll grow by about
3.7 percent this year
but then we should see growth of only
one percent next year and i think look
uh we have seen a contraction on the
month in gdp in the latest figures and i
think what is clear because of the high
inflation we're seeing here uh in the uk
for many households this year it will
feel like a recession we're going to see
the biggest squeeze on household incomes
we expect since records uh began and as
a consequence of that
consumption household spending is likely
to shrink every quarter for the next
four quarters and that's why it's so
important that we keep business
investment going and flowing throughout
our economy so that we can see that
return
to growth and productivity and
increasing living standards here in the
uk which i think we all want to see
we've had the environment secretary on
the program this morning when asked
about those figures his view was pretty
close to that of the chancellor of the
exchequer you know countries around the
world are seeing slowing growth the uk
is not immune from those challenges
essentially saying look we've all got to
kind of grin and bear i mean to what
extent is that true
i mean look at as we've seen in just
that report we're showing us now the
devastating war in the ukraine is having
economic consequences here though of
course our thoughts are immediately with
the devastating human toll that it's
having but yes we've seen rising global
energy prices rising global commodity
prices and that is creating headwinds
for so many uh economies so yes it's
partly about global factors that are
pushing up uh inflation but i think it's
wrong to say there isn't things the
government here can do we've already
seen the chancellor act to help support
the most vulnerable households in our
society but there's much more he could
be doing now to help get business
investment going next year he's been
bold in having a super deduction that's
an incentive to really bring forward
an increased business investment but
that comes to an end next year and
that's exactly when we need to see the
engine of growth uh continuing here in
the uk so we need to see a permanent
investment allowance and we should see
the government accelerating our
transition to a net zero economy now is
the time to really be investing in
renewable energy and making our homes
warmer more energy efficient the
government have had some amount some
programs to help uh vulnerable
households make their homes more energy
efficient but we need we haven't seen
the latest round of that we could
absolutely be accelerating what we're
doing now to get on with delivering
growth in this country i mean i suppose
then from what you're saying rain that
the last thing we really want right now
is a trade war with the european union
something that a few people are
suggesting you know could result from
the changes that we're making to the
northern ireland protocol where do you
fall in that
look we need both sides to absolutely
stay at the table we need a negotiated
outcome the northern ireland protocol
is is working on the ground but it can
absolutely be improved and so for that
we need both sides to stay
at the table we need flexibility from
both sides unilateral action from either
sites is really not going to help we
don't need the uk to walk away from this
but we do need to see more flexibility
from
the european side we absolutely need to
ensure we have a good trading agreement
with our biggest trading partner
i mean
are you perhaps frustrated
at the chancellor and others in
whitehall at the moment then right
i think what we're asking for is to see
the same uh commitment and energy and
with getting growth going in our economy
as we saw during covent we've seen the
chancellor be bold before and he has
acted to support vulnerable households
in this latest crisis but i think we
want to see that spirit from across
government to really get on with the
things that are under their uh control i
don't think now is the time to play
politics we need to see the focus on
action on policies that will deliver for
businesses and households throughout the
economy
newton smith the cbi lovely to have you
on the program this morning take care
thank you